[Music]
hey guys it is issa rae
we are currently in englewood california
shooting
the fifth episode of our fourth season
it's a block party episode it's finally
here i'm so excited to give you a tour
follow me oh okay follow me though
trips me out is that this street is
gonna change so much by next year this
is like a rare opportunity to be able to
do this because obviously
what is changing so much
so we went about choosing these vendors
we surveyed the writer's room obviously
i'm from here apprentice is from here
i personally am so excited about
showcasing real black businesses that we
frequent
we're highlighting specific restaurants
and stores that wouldn't be highlighted
in other shows
come on this is fine
the entire production and set design
team really
planned this since we were shooting the
first episode he said you really did
this
but she didn't really do this our set
design team did so shout out to them
in choosing some of the artists to
represent issa's block party obviously
issa is from la she writes super hard we
wanted to have
the finest of l.a artists
[Music]
[Applause]
vince staple was his election he says
what he wants to say
he is such a dope artist to me we've
been featuring his music since the first
season
i'm such a high-profile artist for east
adidas
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
so the wobble is stable in the black
community
in general so we knew that
in this moment to bring issa and molly
together what better dance
than the wobble to reunite them and so
that was a really fun team to shoot with
300 to 500 extras
and i could not be more proud of the
vision of this block party realized
there was so much time okay you guys i
hope you enjoyed
the block party tour i hope you enjoyed
this episode i actually have to get back
to work i'll catch y'all later
[Music]
bye
you